les officiers les ministères de défense
est prêt à tenir le cours de la session
finale du collège messieurs les
officiers mais celui ci
bonjour chers camarades
nous commencerons notre travail par le
développement des armées et de la
capacité de défendre de défense et nous
avons toujours à corte nous accordons et
nous devons nous allons continuer à
accorder beaucoup d'attention à cet
aspect est aujourd'hui lors de cette
session étendue du collège du ministère
affaires étrangères de la défense nous
allons discuter des objectifs à
l'horizon 2025 et des résultats qui ont
déjà été obtenus en cette voie et nous
allons donc définir quels sont les
objectifs
qui sont revus chaque année
cette année comme l'année précédente
2020 nous cette année a été
extraordinaire nous comprenons tous bien
quel est le problème et dans le contexte
de d'épidémie de corne à vis qui se
poursuit et ce qu'il y a de particulier
dans cette difficulté spécifique
les forces armées de la fédération de
russie ont rempli toutes les missions
qui leur avaient été affectés et donc
des ondes poursuit poursuivi le travail
de modernisation des forces armées nous
avons
[Musique]
61 6%
d'augmentation
et nous avons développé un certain
nombre de formes d'armes
par mail le avant-garde keane jal sont
de nouveaux systèmes d'armes qui ont été
développés
évidemment la marine russe est
complètement
développé pour les navires de surface et
les navets les sous marins dont la
plupart des mers du globe un certain
nombre de missions d'exercice qui
avaient été fixés pour la flotte de la
mer du nord la flotte de la mer baltique
dans des zones éloignées de leçons
pacifique de l'océan atlantique en
matière de repérage de sous-marins
et aussi dans les conditions difficiles
de l'eau sans article
la capacité de défense a été élevée au
niveau pour l'ensemble des forces
russes
nous avons développé des processus de
riposte
et nos soldats en syrie ont également
fait preuve de vaillance et de courage
et notamment en remplissant des missions
d'ordre humanitaire pour le bien de la
population de ce pays
depuis plus d'un an des soldats de la
paix travaillent à maintenir la
stabilité et la paix dans le haut
karabakh
et il ya aussi une situation humanitaire
particulière et notamment ils ont rempli
des missions de déminage de restauration
des voix de transe de communication au
civil et de défense des
des monuments historiques
dans
dans cette complexité
les conflits conditions difficiles et
nos médecins militaires ont rempli des
missions très importantes
avec la mise en place de pitau deux
campagnes et plus de trente mille
personnes ont bénéficié de cette aide
notamment dans en matière de lutte
contre l'infection coronavirus dans neuf
régions de la fédération de russie
et ils sont même travaillé en matière de
convalescence pour ceux qui avaient été
qui avait dû
souffrir de façon grave de cette maladie
et donc on a un certain nombre de
militaires qui sont aujourd'hui en
convalescence dans ces centres de repos
la poursuite de cette lutte contre
l'infection à cornas virus fait que nous
avons quasiment 100% de vaccination dans
les effectifs de l'armée ce qui a évité
une diffusion étendue du virus et en
même temps cela permette de garantir le
fonctionnement normal des unités il ya
quand même eu quelques grains grave dans
l'armée il ya eu des pertes qui ne sont
pas des pertes au combat mais dans
l'ensemble les forces armées se sont
bien acquittés de cette mission
je parle non seulement des volumes des
infrastructures défense armée mais aussi
du fait que les services de construction
ont pu construire un certain nombre
d'équipements et d'installations en
crimée dans d'autres régions et grâce
aux deux nouveaux établissements
médicaux et à vocation sociale ont été
installés en s'appuyant sur la base
forte qui est la nôtre depuis plusieurs
années sur les recherches scientifiques
nous devons poursuivre ce travail de
renforcement de renforcement de nos
forces armées et nous allons continuer
cet effort la situation dans le monde
demeure difficile il ya des zones de
conflit il y à nous de nouveaux foyers
de tensions qui apparaissent et des
sources de préoccupation notamment aux
frontières de la fédération de russie
avec des rassemblements de troupes de
l'otan et américaines nous sommes
préoccupés de voir qu'à proximité des
frontières de la russie la force de
défense antimissile
américaine ne cesse de se développer et
avec notamment des systèmes d'arc
tomahawk
et si cela se poursuit de cette façon si
les systèmes de missiles américains
les de l'otan apparaissent
dans en ukraine ça veut dire que le
temps de vol des missiles occidentaux
jusqu'à moscou serait dur à à 5 ou 10
minutes et à cet égard et comme vous le
savez je
proposerai au président américain
de négocier sur certaines mesures très
concrètes des en réalité d'ailleurs au
cours de la discussion il a lui même
proposé de nommer des responsables pour
gérer ces
négociations et donc nous allons faire
nous continuer à faire nos propositions
pour éviter toute extension de l'otan
les
développements d'armes offensives dans
les territoires adjacents à la
fédération de russie
c'est ce que nous avons informé c'est ce
dont nous avons informé nos collègues de
l'otan et américains il nous faut des
garanties juridiquement contraignante à
long terme et cela est important
mmmmh même ces garanties juridiques ne
nous inspire pas une confiance totale
parce que les américains se retirent de
tous les traités auxquels ils ont
souscrit à un moment ou un autre tôt ou
tard
ils expliquent quelque chose parfois il
n'explique que rien c'est par exemple ce
qui a été le cas en matière de missiles
anti de la défense antimissile mais au
moins est ce que au moins sur le plan
juridique on pourrait avoir des
garanties et non pas des promesses
verbales
et maintenant les paroles les promesses
verbales on les connaît et dans une
histoire
toute récente la fin des années 80 au
début des années 90 quand on nous
promettait que vos inquiétudes à propos
de l'extension de l'otan étaient
infondées
et puis on a eu cinq vague d'extension
de l'otan
et cela ça c'est produit vous vous en
souvenez vous êtes tous grands adultes
vous avez vu cela ça s'est passé au
moment où entre la russie les états unis
la russie tous les pays de l'otan
avaient des relations parfaitement sans
aucun nuage
on était presque des ailiers
et on le disait publiquement hier je
vous le rappelle ray sur des sites des
armements nucléaires
de la fédération de russie il y avait
des spécimens qui étaient là tous les
jours présents sur place ils avaient
leurs bureaux et le drapeau américain
alors qu'est ce qu'on pouvait faire de
plus qu'est ce qu'il leur fallait de
plus encore
il y avait des conseillers américains
qui travaillent qui travaillent dans le
gouvernement russe et qui apporte qui
apporter leurs conseils comme on dit
alors pourquoi encore soutenir le
séparatisme dans le caucase du nord et
encore l'état islamique 9 à papa l'état
islamique mais d'autres organisations
terroristes islamistes ils les
soutenaient ouvertement pourquoi
pourquoi faire ça pour quoi agrandir
l'otan encore pourquoi cette question de
la défense antimissile
tout ce qui se passe aujourd'hui il ya
des tensions qui se mettent c'est leur
faute c'est leur faute à eux à chaque
pas la russie était bien obligé de
répondre à chaque fois à chaque pas la
situation ne faisait que s'aggraver
toujours et toujours et aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans cette situation où nous
sommes obligés de prendre des décisions
on ne peut pas les laisser continuer à
faire dégénérer cette situation
c'est pas clair est ce que quelqu'un qui
ne comprend pas ici ça doit être clair
ça doit être parfaitement clair et on se
pose la question est pourquoi ils ont
fait ça dans ces conditions là on ne
comprend pas je pense que cette euphorie
avec l'allier à ladite victoire à la fin
de la guerre froide
et cette
interprétation
erronée à ce moment là de la situation
et
cette analyse non professionnels
inapproprié voilà tout ce jeu là je vois
pas d'autres raisons à cette situation
encore une fois je tiens à le souligner
nous n'exigeons pas pour nous-mêmes des
conditions particulières la russie et
pour
une égalité de droit à une égalité un
équilibre de la défense sur le continent
européen et les manoeuvres dati mais les
manoeuvres d'intimidation de nos
partenaires seront
aurons une réponse appropriée et je
tiens à le souligner nous avons
parfaitement le droit
de
d'assurer la sécurité la souveraineté de
la fédération de russie nous connaissons
bien sous diverses prétexte pour assurer
leur propre sécurité ils agissent à des
milliers de kilomètres de leur
territoire
et quand le droit international où les
chars de l'onu les gènes il déclare
simplement que ces lois que ces règles
sont démodés
et quand quelque chose convient leurs 21
alors à ce moment là tout de suite il se
réfère au droit international aux droits
humanitaires de chaque peuple etc etc
donc c'est double mesure ces deux poids
deux mesures nous en avons assez
par conséquent nous avons besoin d'avoir
un système de développement de nos
forces armées
systématique régulier avec des missions
tout à fait fixée dans le cadre de la
sécurité nationale et de la conception
de développement des forces armées à
l'horizon 2030 quelles sont ses missions
principales
pour notamment pour l'année prochaine
elle premier point
poursuivre l'équipement de nos forces en
armement de pointe notamment des
systèmes de haute précision en matière
de navigation et de l'atteinte des
cibles deuxième point la formation
milité à la formation au combat doit se
faire en correspondance avec les
armements qui sont en dotation dans les
forums c'est à dire que la formation de
base au groupe doit se faire de façon
collective avec d
un commandement stratégique
au niveau des exercices sur troisième
point
il doit y avoir la capacité de prendre
des décisions rapidement et parce que
évidemment cette vitesse de prise de
décision ne fait que ce d'augmenter
notamment en conditions de combat donc
il faut que tous les niveaux de
commandement ici en particulier au
niveau tactique donc il faut ici mettre
en place une technologie d'intelligence
artificielle approprié quatrième point
il faut qu'il y ait des algorithmes
précis de prise de décision et d'action
avec un des systèmes automatisés parce
qu'on voit que les conflits militaires
souvent se déroule de façon
différente des modèles que nous avons
étudiés donc il faut aussi des qualités
personnelles pour ceux qui prennent ces
décisions
inhabituel donc dans la formation au
combat il est nécessaire d'avoir des
relations inter entre les différents
niveaux de commandement
avec un suivi très précis ddd maintenant
de la progression de carrière pour les
militaires et la 5ème condition c'est
que dans l'acte dans les conditions
difficiles aujourd'hui à l'international
il faut développer la coopération
technico-militaire avec les pays de
l'organisation du traité de shanghai et
développer la capacité de défense de
l'état unifiée russie-biélorussie chers
collègues
une des priorités essentielles
d'amélioration de nos forces armées
c'est la défense des acquis sociaux
parce que c'est une mission importante
d'une grande responsabilité que
remplissent nos militaires et il faut
que nos militaires reçoivent la juste
rétribution de leur travail avec
notamment une augmentation des soldes
comme ça a été déjà lancées il ya
plusieurs années et pas seulement
que ça corresponde aux normes de niveau
de vie dans le pays mais même que ça les
dépasse
pour l'instant je sais qu'on a encore
on a encore un niveau pas tout à fait
satisfaisant on a cinquante cinq mille
salaires en
pour les niveaux moyens alors que par
exemple dans les milieux de transport
pétrolier financier s'est on est à 63
mille roubles par mois d'après les
données que j'ai ici
le ministère de la finance donne des
niveaux un peu différent
et par exemple on les statistiques on a
on a par exemple
88 mille deux cents pour un militaire au
grade de lieutenant
donc c'est un niveau moyen
dans les secteurs économiques les plus
dynamiques on est à 60 3200 donc le
gouvernement doit continuer en temps et
en heure et dans les volumes nécessaires
indexer la solde des militaires
et enfin
augmenter le niveau des retraites pour
les militaires
avec les fournir des
logement
permanent nous avons accordé des
allocations pour le logement pour plus
de quatre mille trois cent cinquante
militaires
et ce montant peut être de deux mille
roubles par mois
et cela représente 113 milliards de
roubles à l'année donc il ya un système
de crédits au logement qui doivent qui
avait été lancé il ya quelques années
et qui a bénéficié à quinze mille
militaires en 2021 et ça devrait
augmenter à plus de 20000
les logements de service doivent être
affectés aussi déjà 3 35 mille
militaires en ont bénéficié cette année
et nous allons poursuivre
aux enfants et aux autres catégories
sociales dépendante des militaires
d'autres avantages et pour conclusion en
conclusion je voudrais remercier
le commandement du ministère de la
défense et l'ensemble des effectifs pour
le travail que vous accomplissez pour la
mission que vous remplissiez vous le
faites ça d'eux de façon professionnelle
vous faites tout ce qui est nécessaire
pour satisfaire les objectifs qui ont
été fixés et je vous souhaite un plein
succès pour le bien de la russie et de
notre peuple je vous remercie pour votre
attention
monsieur le commandant en chef
on continue à témoigner l'aggravation de
la situation politique et militaire dans
le monde avec à l'os de tension à des
frontières occidentales et orientales de
la russie et les etats-unis renforcent
leur présence près des frontières russes
et dans les pays de l'europe orientale
qui ont abrité les troupes américaines
au niveau de 8000 à militaire le
groupement des troupes
des états unis à restaurer le
commandement qui existait sur le
territoire allemand 1 jusqu'à
[Musique]
jusqu'à récemment ils ont formé une
brigade qui serait doté de différents
systèmes de missiles de frappe en
pologne est en train de créer
l'infrastructure pour abriter
leurs structures blanc des états unis
ont permis la création de l'ensemble
de défense antimissile en roumanie les
sites de défense anti missile eux sont
déjà mises en service on continue à
développer le segment
de ces deux systèmes antimissile dans la
zone de pacific pour contrôler les
communications
océanique en atlantique en europe a été
créée au commandement uni des forces de
l'otan le temps et les etats unis
s'efforcent à
renforcer les manoeuvres mais les terres
près des frontières russes le plus en
plus souvent
l'aviation stratégique y participent en
y mettant des lancements des missiles
nucléaires le la quantité des foules de
ses avions près de mort la frontière a
été doublée de récemment on est surtout
préoccupé à la projection des taupes à
la proximité des frontières de la russie
pendant les manoeuvres militaires ont à
simuler différents types de
d'activité avec la participation des
pays qui ne font pas partie de deux le
temps comme la géorgie le kremlin la
moldavie en essayant de faire appliquer
les forces armées des pays ne faisant
pas partie du traité compte tenu les
tentatives de quiévrain à résoudre le
problème de donbass et par le vote force
le
l'aménagement militaire de territoire
ukrainien par les pays de l'otan et
continue le
les livraisons des missiles antichars
des drones
sont réalisés sur le territoire
ukrainien
on voit la présence des représentants
des sociétés militaires privées
dans les lequel étaient près de
république autonome qui font aménager
les postes de commandement et de tirer
entre m les militaires craignent un art
elysées dea provocation à ce titre assez
fend les réserves dans agents chimiques
non identifiés ont été
transportés à la localité à venir car
les militaires eux craignant ne cesse
pas de lancer des tirs contre les
localités de john bass et les civils
dedans basse aussi bien que contre le
déploiement des forces de défense
cette instabilité crée des risques et
d'exportation du terrorisme et de trafic
de toutes sortes sur les territoires des
pays du traité d'une organisation du
traité de sécurité collective
un facteur supplémentaire influençant le
contexte et c'est
la pandémie de cornet virus le ministère
de défense a pris des mesures
systémiques et pour contrer ce fléau ce
qui nous a permis d'assurer le niveau à
2,3 fois inférieur au niveau moyen du
pays il s'agit de la contamination du
personnel et d'effectifs
on a augmenté le nombre des tests
jusqu'au niveau de 50000 par ce même ce
qui est largement supérieur aux normes
or à la réglementation en vigueur
le délai des essais des tests de paix
sert de quelques heures seulement nous
avons des systèmes que nous permet de
vérifier les t 130 minutes 100 % des
effectifs militaires sont vaccinés 70%
des civils impliqués dans le dans les
organismes de le ministère de la défense
les forces armées ont atteint en
humidité collectif total grâce à votre
soutien mais sur le président pendant au
moins quand anne qu'une année on a su
construire toutes les cités du vent si
tu y es ma centre de recherche du
ministère de défense et qui ne sert à
nos gars liste des basses pour le
développement la création des
médicaments visant tu apparais la menace
du corner virus tout aux ordonnances
visanthe à
assister les
la population de 39 régions de la
fédération de russie est de 7 et pays
étrangers
toutes ces ordonnances ont été rempli
pleinement
en 2020 nous avons construit trente deux
hôpitaux militaires qui joue un rôle
actif pour la lutte contre la pandémie
sur le territoire national l'ensemble de
ces mesures anti que vida permet de
garder une haute efficacité
opérationnelle des forces armées de la
fédération de russie pourrait rester en
mesure de remplir toutes les missions
confiées
l'état des forces armées
la quantité des personnels me parmi des
officiers scellé au niveau de 4 16%
cette année près de mille officiers ont
été promus des écoles mais les terres la
quantité des militaires ce contrat est
double par rapport à ceux qui font le
service national
60% d'entre ces antres c'est un
militaire de carrière on a suivi à
l'enseignement supérieur où
l'enseignement professionnel les forces
armées ont complété leur effectif à 80
ans pour sa 91 % à 92 % ont fait le
complet des postes pour les forces
aériennes au nab sur udr le problème de
long terme a dit consiste à fournir aux
militaires des habitats de long terme
cette année à plus de 19
mille cinq cents personnes ont reçu des
appartements à permanent pendant l'année
en cours 35000 personnes henri sur les
appartements de service 64 mille
militaires en russie une compensation
pour la location des habitats pour leur
famille et ceux qui renforcent la
confiance des effectifs des forces
armées le renforce on a su renforcer
l'efficacité opérationnelle
en
dotant le 1er régiment
des missiles avant-garde
ayant des blocs elle est super sonique
est encore deux régiments des forces
stratégiques ont été dotés de insisté
maillard ce les forces stratégiques
nucléaires ont été équipés de quatre
nouveaux avions porte en gens nus clair
en nouveau un sous-marin ans a été mis
en service pour la flotte qui il est
équipé des missile balistique boulava
grâce à cette activité systémique sous
la direction de commandant supérieur le
niveau d'efficacité opérationnelle de
notre à la triade nucléaire s'élève à
89,1 % la livraison des deux nouveaux
missiles est suivie de la création b ase
enfants structures appropriées cette
année maubleu de 90 sites ont été
construits
de nombreux échantillons ont été envoyés
dans les troupes de nouvelles divisions
d'infanterie et blindés ont été créés
dans l'est dans l'armée de l'air et de
l'espace des régiments de décès à ont
été organisées et 2 p de 50 et en
échantillon de nouveaux équipements les
détachements de défense
anti aérienne ont été dotés de nouveau
un spécimen d'armement en nouveaux
régiments doté des avions mig et 31 et
armés de missiles
et personnic qui gèle
le cinquième en jean spatiale coupole a
été lancé on a terminé la construction
d'un poste de commandement
spécialisé pour les forces cosmiques him
on a terminé les essais dans drones de
l'emporter altus roues à on a commencé
les livraisons des systèmes de frappe de
reconnaissance fort postes qui sont déjà
livrés dans les armées
en 29e aérodrome à pendant cette année
on a fait les travaux de restauration de
remise à niveau des pistes de décollage
et d'atterrissage ce qui permet
d'exploiter
toutes sortes du matériel militaire
nouvellement admis par les années parler
les armes et la marina richer quatre
navires de surface dix sept vedettes et
trois assists est mort de missiles
côtier cette année la marine a su former
quatre nouvelles unités y compris une
unité en régiment d'artillerie et en
régiment de génie
marrant
sont déjà presque terminé les tirs
d'essai du missile
hypersonique a embarqué cirque own qui
sera livré dans la marine de récemment à
gadji ve on est en train de terminer la
construction des locaux pour
l'hébergement de services qui visent à
la visite à m héberger les marrons et
les membres de leur famille durant les
quatre ans de suite les forces
aéroportées les troupes aéroportées ont
reçu plus de 500 ha spécialement des du
matériel nouvellement elle adorait ce
qui a permis de créer de nouveaux et
régiment aéroporté alors de la manière
les missions de réarmement qui sont
confiées par le commandant en chef
sont remplis pas par pas
la dotation des armements modernes et
s'élève à plus de 70% après se7en 10
nous avons des positions de leader dans
le monde tandis que nous ne sommes que
neuvième pour le budget militaire grâce
à la gestion opérationnelle des
ressources financières
plus de
80 millions de roubles seront destinés à
la livraison des armes de haute
précision ce que nous permettra
d'augmenter à 30% le nombre de ce type
d'armement dont nos troupes sont dotées
on est en train d'intégrer plusieurs
nouveautés dans le cadre de réalisation
du programme de réarmement et et de
réalisation de la commande à militaires
auprès de l'industrie de défense les
contrats d'état assure la livraison
qu'opportune des du matériel dans les
troupes en même temps en assurant la
charge nécessaire de l'industrie de
défense dont le niveau se lit à 81 3% un
exemple positif de ce programme c'est la
création de à 34
navires de surface et des sous marins
qui sera réalisé d'ici plusieurs années
ce qui permettra d'ici
2020 cette eau 2 et
2033 dans le cadre d'un nouveau
programme de réarmement on
profite de les approcher systémique à
horaire mais man des troupes en signant
le contrat direct avec les fabricants en
utilisant leurs 10 du prix d'une heure
de vol en ce qui concerne les armes f à
qui sont destinés à l'armée de l'air ce
qui a permis de maintenir l'efficacité
opérationnelle des aéronefs au niveau de
83 % ce qui est deux fois supérieur à
aux mêmes caractéristiques de 2013 nous
avons créé un système unique d le
surveillance des commandes passées à
l'industrie et visant à contrôler
l'utilisation des fonds débloqués par
l'état c'est un outil avancé visant à
remplir les missions dont nous sommes
chargés grâce à ce système nonobstant
des restrictions existantes nous avons
eu 4 à 99 4 % de commandes accompli
l'efficacité opérationnelle des troupes
reste au niveau nécessaire
la formation
parmi les essenciers les manoeuvres de
formation on compte les manoeuvres
occident
2020 vente et en les antes assurer la
sécurité régionale ces manoeuvres ont
nécessité la participation de plusieurs
milliers de militaires y compris deux
mille militaires venus des pays de
l'organisation de coopération de
shanghai durant ces manoeuvres des
systèmes robotisés ont été utilisés le
forces armées en réaliser toutes sortes
de mesures prévues de formation
militaire y compris 45 à manoeuvre
internationaux cette année pendant les
contrôles inopinés des de l'efficacité
opérationnelle
les troupes ont ce fonds dû être protégé
à plus de 3500 kilomètres pour remplir
les missions dans les polygones en
dehors de leur zone de responsabilité
pour la première fois dans la liste war
moderne de la russie et la flotte de
pacific a participé à ces manoeuvres
dans la zone éloignée maritime pendant
ces manoeuvres la flotte à réaliser le
déploiement discret dans une région
éloignée à l'archipel française
joseph
une
manoeuvre une car a été réalisé dans les
conditions
du nord en profitant de tout le matériel
moderne les manoeuvres ont été réalisés
et les missions et les objectifs ont été
remplis les manoeuvres
internationaux tout en plis ké 11
états avec l'application devant 6000
militaires venus de 42 pays
de plus d'un million et demi de
personnes ont assisté à ces manoeuvres
là le contexte actuel nous a permis de
renforcer le niveau de formation et de
professionnalisme des commandants de
troupes
les missions étrangères
le contingent de maintien de la paix
russes continuent à remplir ses missions
dans le haut karabakh plusieurs milliers
d'engins explosifs ont été déminés vont
deux campagnes humanitaires ont été
réalisés ce qui n'a pas permis de
maintenir le cessez le feu pendant une
année entière
le groupement russe des troupes reste là
le gerrans essentiel de maintien de la
paix en syrie ce qui nous a permis de
parer la hausse de tension dans le pays
ne dataient de cet été grâce à la
participation de nos conseillers on a su
éviter
des hostilités nous avons réalisé plus
de 3000 de campagne humanitaire à plus
de 3000 tonnes des marchandises ont été
les vrais les 1100 militaires en
traiter les champs médicaux à 130 civils
nous avons
conditionner la rentrée de plusieurs
millions des civils à leur
invitation d'avant la guerre
allait retomber mime nous avons terminé
les travaux
d'agrandissement de la piste des colères
de teris age and armini nous avons
terminé la construction d'un
gymnase salle de gym et de sport un peu
plusieurs mille mètres carrés le
ministère de la défense assure la
coopération avec les forces armées 209
pays du monde ce qui témoigne encore une
fois la vanité des
les efforts des pays occidentaux a
assuré notre isolation nous continuons
notre opération étroite avec les pays de
l'organisation
du traité de sécurité collective et de
l'organisation de coopération de
shanghai nous avons réalisé cette année
de manoeuvre conjointe avec les forces
armées chinoises me partenaire essentiel
dans la coopération
militaro technique ce sont la chine le
vietnam l'egypte aime bien demain au
mois de juin nous avons à organiser la
9e conférence internationale du moscow
pour la sécurité ou les participants de
sang neuf pays ont participé
c'est un événement politico militaire le
plus représentatif dans le monde le
renforcement de la coopération militaro
technique qui a été assurée par le
feront main armée 2021 avec la
participation 217 représentants des pays
étrangers plusieurs millions de
visiteurs ont vu sept taureaux ont
assisté à cette
conférence grâce aux établissements
d'enseignement militaire nous avons créé
en
lieu unique numérique de formation nous
avons organisé
[Musique]
la reprise de 13000 lé vos fichiers
dans les établissements d'enseignement
et militaires
le concours moyen est de six candidats
pour une place vacante et pour les
femmes ce chiffre s'élève à 17 on
renforce la formation parmi les
étudiants des établissements civile
qui font leur stage dans l'est un centre
militaire les
élèves de l'école militaire de homs qui
ont été dotés de nouveaux matériels de
formation d'autres écoles militaires ont
été équipés des piscines et b sens et
des sites de sport on termine la
création des écoles et spécialisée pour
les enfants
doués
aaa n'a pas
la sécurité sociale
grâce à vous monsieur le président la
mission d'adp renforcement de la
sécurité sociale des militaires qui
remplissent leur devoir à dans des
conditions liées avec le risque à leur
vie
181 milliards de roubles ont été
débloqués à ses enfants cette année les
soldes des militaires ont été en d'excès
à 3 7%
pour le futur on prévoit une indexation
encore plus forte
les mesures prises en force
l'attractivité de du service dans les
armées
le ministère de la défense a su créer un
système efficace d'interaction avec des
autorités publiques à visant à assurer
la sécurité
sociale des familles des militaires ce
qui nous a permis de renforcer
le
d'éliminer les déficiences pour les
loyers et pour les places dans les
écoles maternelles pour les familles des
militaires
nous avons lancé le programme les
partenaires de l'armée russe tous les
militaires auront rendu l'accès à des
remises jusqu'à 30% pour en large
éventail des marchandises et des
produits dans l'arche maillage des
magasins qui participent dans le
programme les programmes de
développement de la médecine militaire
ont servi à la rendre au niveau
supérieur dans tout le pays nos sommes
en mesure de donner des soins médicaux
médicaux à distance les mesures prises
ont permis de réduire le niveau au moyen
de contaminations parmi les militaires
cette année notre poche de construction
et aux mises en service
trois sites à moscou saint pétersbourg
et à vladikavkaz ce qui a permis de
renforcer les soins médicaux
distribués aux militaires et membres de
leurs familles d'après fo
d'après vos ordonnances les programmes
paris sont réalisées à saint-pétersbourg
à moscou dans la région de toula la
surface totale des sites en construction
s'élèvent à 80 mille mètres carrés
l'aménagement des troupes
dans les îles arctiques et des archipels
on a terminé la création de deux bases
militaires
qui servent à organiser le service est
permanent d
de la défense anti-aérienne et de
l'artillerie côtière en termine à
l'aménagement des ports qui est sûr
qu'ils seront en mesure de
la bri et tous types de navires
nous
nous apportons la
l'attention particulière
aux zones arctiques et du nord dans
150 points de déploiement des troupes
plus de 170 tonnes milles tonnes de deux
différents marchandises ont été livrés
on continue les mesures visant à
éliminer l'impact négatif écologique en
arctique à plusieurs milliers de tonnes
des débris métalliques ont été
amassés et à enlever des zones arctiques
cette année nous avons réalisé plusieurs
projets or dans le délai de quatre à
sept mois ce qu'a été ce qui était
rendue probable possible grâce aux
nouvelles approches pour hansen roubles
débloquer on a deux roubles des
investissements
nous réalisons des mesures planifiées
pour l'aménagement des sites et
militaires on a terminé 1 2 on a terminé
la construction de 692
bâtiment dans le cadre de ce programme
on continue le programme de partenariat
les ans à la construction des systèmes
de ravitaillement en carburant dans les
aérodromes avec la participation des
sociétés pétrolières qui ont débloqué à
peu près 30 millions de roubles à ses
fins on a su construire 66 dépôt moderne
et le rat quantité totale s'élève
maintenant à 602 on a su réduire les
frais mal fondé pour les services
communaux à hama installant des
compteurs
des services communaux aux sites
militaires
grâce aux
efforts de nos troupes ferroviaire le
bas est reconstruit à avec une avance
par rapport au projet au secteur power
quality nous avons a commencé la mise de
nos chemins de fer on poursuit le projet
poursuit le programme de remise à des
locales à des autorités locales des
sites en france structurelles militaire
qui ne sont pas impliqués dans notre
activité à quotidienne les moyens
débloqués de la sorte ont utilisé pour
améliorer la situation actuelle des
militaires dans les cités militaire
cette année nous avons continué à
renforcer le niveau du moral des troupes
et en pour assurer leur efficacité
opérationnelle à toutes sortes de
contexte en même temps le l'étendue des
missions qui nous sont confiées par les
hommes politiques militaires et
de plus en plus grands portant à l'année
anniversaire de la guerre de la victoire
à la grande guerre patriotique nous
avons organisé des défilés militaires
dans de nombreuses villes russes on a
organisé des faits les marines
80,6 drapeau militaires ont été rendus
dans le musée le
nos musées
est maintenant très apprécié par les
populations on a su organiser plus d'une
centaine des événements occupe plus de
trois millions d'habitants ont visité
4 248 parquet pas de type patriot ont
été créés par tout le pays on continue
la formation parmi les jeunes notre
organisation youn a remis à l'armée
jeunes à a déjà plusieurs millions
d'adhérents
ensemble avec
le champ du boult secoué divergents du
moscou nous avons organisé le programme
avant garde pour la formation des jeunes
pendant cette année plus de 10000
adolescents et adolescentes ont suivi la
formation dans le cadre de ce programme
on continue ce programme dans les villes
avec
100000 habitants et plus d'après votre
ordonnance 40 centres par éhontée déjà
été créés cette année nous avons créé en
site
multifonctionnel de télévision qui
permet de s
informer les populations sur
l'activité du ministère de défense
alors on a créé tout le nécessaire pour
la le tournage des films patriotiques à
la demande du ministère de défense ou
d'autres services concernés monsieur le
chef suprême des armées toutes les
missions confiées pour l'année 2000 21
ont été remplis par les forces armées de
la russie nos capacités opérationnelles
se sont sont les renforcer la
réalisation de tous les contrats et
réaliser la livraison de plus de 5000
type d'armement et était assurée nous
avons su maintenir
l'efficacité opérationnelle au niveau de
95 % pour nos matériels plus de 3000
bâtiment avec la surface totale de 2 5
millions de mètres carrés en 2021 le
volume total des investissements
capitaux s'élève à plus de 155 meilleur
du rouble à ce qui nous a permis de
réduire considérablement le volume au
des sites de construction inachevée le
ministre l'activité du ministère de
défense est vraiment apprécié dans la
population par la population russe à peu
près 90% de la population sont sûrs que
les forces armées sont en mesure de
défendre la patrie et +2
88% de la population questionner sont
fiers d'avoir des forces armées d'un
pareil là pour l'année 2000 vent de
vente et une rampe de lancement avec les
missiles balistiques entre continental
ya ce avant garde et samara doit être
mise en service les forces stratégiques
nucléaires doivent recevoir deux avions
porte en jean-mi si important genre
nucléaire un
tout 160 m pour les forces
conventionnelles
l'armée de terre doit recevoir
plus de 11000
d'unités d'armement aux blindés et des
chars les l'armée de l'air et
la marine doit recevoir
250 cet art neuf hommes modernes 5 et
système s 400 triumph la marine doit à
prendre cinq pieds somaro 11 navires de
surface et les troupes de défenses
côtières doivent recevoir deux systèmes
de défense côtier
le nombre des militaires ce contrat doit
être renforcée de quatre
1700 personnes
4 300 à 1000 bâtiments doivent être
mises en service un simultanément avec
la fourniture de nouveaux matériels et
armement a pendant trois années nos
preuves voyons de réduire le nombre
d'effectifs dans le commissariat
militaire le ministère de défense est
rempli en gros travail pour renforcer la
capacité de défense du pays mais nous
avons encore beaucoup à faire à l'heure
pendant plusieurs années
on a vu s'accumuler en grande tenue
une grande quantité des réparations
nécessaires nous allons adresser le
demandent au gouvernement pour a
augmenté le budget dédié à ses fins
d'ici la fin de l'année nous prévoyons
terminé
de dresser l'inventaire de zabita de
service pour assurer les réparations
nécessaires monsieur le commandant
suprême des forces armées d'après vos
ordonnances durant l'année prochaine
nous allons poursuivre notre activité
visant à développer les forces armées et
renforcer leurs capacités
opérationnelles
le bilan sera discuté et présenté lors
de la partie applause de de notre
collège aujourd'hui j'ai terminé mon
intervention monsieur le président
vous savez j'aimerais ajouter deux mots
de façon informelle à ce cas ce que
vient de dire le ministre de la défense
qu'est ce que j'avais dit aussi en mode
introduction c'est à dire
on en parle tous et les forces armées
bien évidemment ce sont les premiers en
parle qu'on parlait
ces sont les accords les contrats qui
avaient été
conclus avec les états unis
visant à assurer la stabilité
stratégique et avec l'otan aussi et nous
voyons que certains deux
interprètes de façon tout à fait hostile
disons les choses clairement comme un
ultimatum est ce que c'est un hématome
non bien sûr ce n'en est pas un je
rappelle encore une fois et je tiens à
le rappeler
ce que tout ce qu'ont fait nos
partenaires comme on les appelle les
états unis ces dernières années
pour assurer
prétendument lors intérêts et leur
sécurité à des dizaines de milliers de
km2 de leur territoire il le faisait de
la façon la plus ferme et la plus
manifeste
sans aucune sanction du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu ils sont bombardé la
yougoslavie
quelles étaient leurs motifs ils avaient
l'autorisation du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu où ella jugnot sa vie où sont les
états unis ils ont détruit le pays oui
il y avait un conflit interne y avait
des problèmes spécifiques mais qui leur
a donné le droit de d'effectuer des
frappes sur des capitales européennes
personnes
ils ont simplement décidé
voilà ils ont ils on sautille et aboyer
et voilà et c'est ça le droit
international pour eux
selon qu'elle prêtait sont ils entrés en
irak
l'élaboration d'armes de destruction
massive en irak d'où ils ont détruit ce
pays ils ont construit un foyer de
terrorisme international et puis après
ah désolé on s'est trompé il aux 10 as
et le renseignement qui s'est trompé ah
bah bravo c'est le renseignement
militaire qui a détruit un pays et voila
voila pour toutes où
il s'est trouvé qu'il n'y avait aucune
arme de destruction massive
et
donc ils ont tout détruit voilà
et on syrie comme ils sont bien sûr est
ce qu'il ya eu une autorisation du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu mme
delaunay
ce qu'il veut le faire ils le font mais
ce qu'ils font maintenant sur le
territoire de l'ukraine ou en tout cas
qu'il tente de faire
c'est pas des milliers de kilomètres de
nos frontières c'est juste devant le
seuil de notre maison ils doivent
comprendre que nous n'avons plus de
territoire pour reculer plus loin des
n'en parle constamment avec les
spécialistes nous sommes en contact
permanent il nous savons très bien quand
leur armement de pointe apparaîtra on
sait très bien tout est suivie
les et leurs essais on sait si ça marche
et ça marche pas on sait en gros à peu
près quand ce sera prêt
et alors ils installeront ce désarmement
hypersonique en ukraine et après sous sa
couverture qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
nous on a le cirque ont ils l'ont pas
encore
donc on sait pas ce qu'il va se passer
demain
mais sous cette couverture
il arme et vont inciter les extrémistes
des pays voisins contre la russie
notamment contre certaines régions
spécifiques de la russie par exemple la
grille mais
sous une forme favorable pour eux est ce
qu'ils croient vraiment que nous ne
voyons pas ces menaces est-ce qu'il
pense que nous allons regarder les bras
croisés sans rien dire toutes ces
menaces c'est là tout le problème
on n'a nulle part où reculer encore
toute la question est là
les conflits armés les effusions de sang
ce n'est absolument pas notre choix nous
ne voulons absolument pas à une telle
évolution des de la situation nous
voulons avoir des garanties claires
des garanties qu'ils soient juridiques
clairement établie voilà c'est la
proposition que nous avons exposé sur le
papier que nous avons adressé à
washington
et nous espérons recevoir des réponses
claires et exhaustive il y à certains
signaux
qui montrent que nos partenaires
partenaires seraient prêts à discuter
avec nous mais il y à un danger
et ce danger c'est que il cherche à
gagner du temps en discutant à nous
envoyer dans un marais et que et pour y
enterrer toutes nos propositions et
profiter de cette pause pour faire ce
qu'ils veulent et pour que tout le monde
comprenne bien
en tout cas nous nous le comprenons bien
et une telle évolution de la situation
ne nous satisfait évidemment pas
nous voulons un
d'une discussion ouverte franche
avec des résultats tangibles perceptible
à un horizon tout à fait raisonnable à
moyen terme et nous allons chercher à
obtenir justement des réponses des
résultats mais cela ne peut se faire que
si
on a un véritable développement de nos
forces armées ces dernières années nous
avons pu le faire nous avons obtenu un
niveau satisfaisant
de
d'aptitude au combat je le dis et le
ministre vient de faire son rapport le
rythme de développement est correct dean
il y encore des questions qui doivent
être
traitées encore nous y travaillons post
en permanence et deux fois par an nous
nous réunissons à sotchi est d'abord
parce qu'il fait beau et que tout le
monde va là bas et on peut oublier tout
le reste des questions et on peut
s'occuper uniquement de la défense m et
ces discussions sont tout à fait
constructive et
détaillez les questions sont nombreuses
mais nous les résoudre et je compte
beaucoup que nous puissions continuer à
travailler à ce rythme cela est
nécessaire pour assurer la sécurité de
la russie et de ses citoyens je vous
remercie et je vous souhaite de bonnes
fêtes
messieurs les officiers
messieurs le dossier
oui